What I wanted to do in this video is familiarize ourselves with one of the most important molecules in biology
And that is Glucose
sometimes referred to as Dextrose
and the term Dextrose comes from the fact
that the form of Glucose typically
Typically found in nature if you form a solution of it, it's going to polarize light to the right and Dextre means
Right
But the more typical term glucose this literally means sweet in greek if you ask a greek friend to say sweet
it sounds like Lucas or I'm not saying it perfectly, but it sounds a lot like a glucose
And that's because that's where the word comes from and it is super important because it is it is it is how
energy [is] stored and transferred in biological systems in fact right [now] when if someone were to talk about your blood your blood sugar
they're talking about the glucose content, so when people talk about blood
blood sugar they're talking about your they're talking about your glucose content the whole process of photosynthesis
this is all about plants using harnessing the [sun's] energy and
storing that energy in the form of glucose when we talk about when we talk about things like
respiration in our in our cells cellular respiration
that's all about taking glucose and using it to full and to create atp's which are the molecular currency of energy
Inside of our body, so these are in credit is an incredibly important molecule
We can start wreaking chains of glucose to form Glycogen to form
Starches this along with another similar another simple sugar fructose you can use to form our table sugar
But even glucose by itself is sweet so let's get familiar with it as a molecule
so immediately
When you look at this is it kind of drawn as a as an open chain we see that we have one two three
Actually, let me number these we have one two
three four five six carbons, so
chemical formula would be C
sub six a subscript of six we have how many hydrogen's
How many hydrogen's we have we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 hydrogen's?
C6H12 and then we have how many oxygens do we have?
Have one two three four five six oxygens
Six oxygens, so you might notice we have six carbons and then the ratio for every one oxygen
We have two hydrogen's which is really the ratio of Hydrogen's to oxygens in
Water and if we want to really if we really want to if we add obviously here
We don't have just two hydrogen's and one oxygen
We have 12 hydrogen's and six oxygens, but it's really good to even just familiarize yourselves with what are the different parts here
So we see on the number one carbon it is part of a carbonyl group
when a carbon is bonded to
double bonded to an oxygen like that. That's a carbonyl
Carbonyl
carbonyL group and in fact because this carbon
it's double bonded to an oxygen, but then it's other bonds are I guess you could say a
Carbon chain right over here and then but this other bond right here is a hydrogen
we would call this an aldehyde we would call this an
aldehyde group and it makes Al
Aldehyde and it would officially make the entire molecule an aldehyde if you contain an aldehyde group
You are an aldehyde, so glucose
and when it's written when it's drawn as a straight chain or it's a straight chain form it would be considered an aldehyde and then
Of course it has all these hydroxyl groups on them, and these hydroxyl groups these O-H groups over here
That would officially make glucose also it would officially make it an alcohol, and it's neat to keep in mind
How the structure is so you have six carbons?
One of them is part of this aldehyde group
It's part of this carbonyl right over here
And then the other five are each bonded to a hydroxyl and what I've oriented it this way
four of the hydroxyls are on the right-hand side and the one on the three carbon is on the left-hand side and
all of the other carbon bonds are with
hydrogen carbon likes to form four covalent bonds every one of these six carbons has formed four covalent bonds
And so you would fill up all the rest once you've accounted for this carbonyl here
And you've accounted for all of these hydroxyls everything else is going to be hydrogen
Now this is when you've drawn when you've drawn glucose just as a straight chain
but many times you will see it in its cyclical form
It's neat to kind of think of how do you go from this form to this form over here?
And so what I've drawn here is this exact same this exact open chain
But I've started to I've started to bend it a little bit and just to be able to keep track of things let's renumber
The carbons, so this is the carbon. That's part of the carbonyl group
So it's carbon one and then we number up from there two three
four five
And then that is the number six carbon the reason why I've made these this bond over here nice and fat is
To show that it's it's kind of closer to us
It's popping out of the page and as we go from the the second carbon of the first carbon
We're going back into the page when we go from the third carbon to the fourth Carbon
We are going we are going back into the page right over here, so this big fat bond. This is
between Carbon three and Carbon two, that's this
That's this right over here and this going from two to one
That's this bond
And I'll draw it a little bit kind of going in and then this bond is
This bond right over here and so it take a second pause the video if you need but try to orient yourself to orient yourself
Imagine we're going to take this to the right like this to bring it over here
And then we're going to rotate we're going to rotate this end and bend it up backwards like that
To get to this form C six is now bent all the way up is now rotated all the way up there
We've bent we've bent this chain and the whole reason is is because this will typically react the hydroxyl group
This is it
This is the the most typical form of glucose you will see when you see in a sick little form there's actually other forms that
You can have but the oxygen that forms a hydroxyl group on the fifth carbon
it can it can attack it can attack the the
The number one carbon that forms this carbonyl group
And that's because oxygen we've talked a lot about it is very electronegative likes to hog electrons
So this carbon is partially positive and so you could take one of the lone pairs
You could take one of this oxygen right over here. It's going to have two lone pairs
Let me just draw them as neatly as I can that's one lone pair, and then this is another lone pair right over here
so this oxygen
can
Form a bond with this carbon when we learn organic chemistry and more depth, we'd call that a nucleophilic attack
it sounds very fancy. Just the fact that these are drawn to each other this has a partially positive charge this guy has a
lone pairs of electrons that can be used to form bonds with things and so when that when those electrons form this bond or
Bond to this carbon that's going to be this bond
this Bond right
over here
And then this carbon can let go this carbon can let go of the electrons in
One of these let me do this in a more obvious color
and in the double bond right [over] here it could let go of one of the bonds the electrons in one of the bonds and
then that can be taken back by the oxygen or even better that can be used by that oxygen to capture a
Hydrogen proton in the solution and actually probably part of a
Hydronium Molecule
But let me just draw it this way
this would just be used to capture a
Hydrogen proton that would just be a hydrogen a hydrogen atom without its electron. It's just a hydrogen ion
It would just be a hydrogen proton and that would form this bond
That would form this bond right over here and let me let me just be very clear this carbon this carbon right over here is
This carbon right over there this oxygen this oxygen is
This oxygen is that oxygen right over there, and so hopefully you see how it forms a cyclone. You're probably saying Oh, wait wait
don't we have a little hydrogen attached here
isn't the way I've drawn it looks like there's an extra hydrogen over here, and then that would leave this guy with a
Positive charge we leave with a positive charge, but you can imagine we're in a solution of water then hey
I have some I have another water molecule right over here
And you know these things are all bouncing around and interacting in different ways
But it could use let me do that in the right color it could use
So that's oxygen it could use one of its lone pairs instead of this you know this will become positive temporarily
But then it can use it can do it can use one of its lone pairs to grab just the hydrogen proton which would allow
Which will allow this character to take its to take its
Electrons to take these electrons back and turn into this character and just be neutral and then this this guy
Would have gained so we have a proton going into the solution you have hi
But we took a proton from [the] solution
We took a proton we gave a proton to the solution
And so you could end up with this so the whole reason I did
This is [just] so when you see it in biology class or chemistry class you're not intimidated by it in fact
This is something that's really valuable to get very very familiar [with] because you're going to see
Glucose and other sugars in many many many different molecules
throughout your academic career